have you seen attachment disorder in
Disney because you look at pretty much
in um you know I grew up with The Little
Mermaid Cinderella Snow White Aladdin
and if you look at each one of their
backgrounds they all had attachment
disorders so Ariel uh where was her mama
I don't know where her mama was you know
where my mom I don't even know her mom
looks like you know I remember her daddy
but I don't remember where her mama was
I think her mama died Ursula
and that's how she got caught up in that
witchcraft by the way because she didn't
have a mama is Media affecting how you
connect with other people around you
find out on this episode of LED live
foreign
[Music]
welcome to another episode of LED live
everyone we want to thank you for tuning
in every week and being faithful
Watchers we also want to thank those of
you who donate whether through patreon
or through our website you are the ones
that help keep this program going and we
appreciate that so thank you as well if
you are a donor hopefully you are
getting those behind the scenes uh
little tidbits that we put out as well
if not let us know we want to make sure
that you guys are getting all the extra
content that you deserve today we're
going to talk a little bit about
relationships and we have a guest with
us this is danitra Gary and danitra is a
licensed counselor she actually has her
Masters and so we're going to probe her
with questions about an interesting
topic we're going to talk about
attachment disorder and so to throw it
your way real quick to Nitra can you
tell us a little bit about or our
audience what is attachment disorder why
is that something that any of us should
be concerned about
while attachment disorder is a disorder
that impacts how we connect with people
in relationships okay so it really
affects everyone that we connect with
it's
um one of the basic basic theories in
attachment disorder is your internal
working model and that's how you connect
with
um yourself how you how you understand
yourself how you connect with others and
I kind of rephrased it and changed it to
how you connect with God so it just um
affects our overall self-concept our
overall self-image okay so is there
anything in particular that you look at
like connections with your spouse or
significant other or connections with
your parents or connections with your
child or all of it do you deal with any
of those specifically are you dealing
with all those all the time well I deal
with all of them all the time okay
um I think that as a result of the sin
problem as a result of the great
controversy that we are in everybody has
attachment Disorder so we all come out
um the off the bat we start out at in
the negative and depending on where your
relationship is with your parents in
your formative years that it kind of
predicates
um the the trajectory of how you will
relate to other people in relationships
so how you will relate to your spouse
how you will relate to your friends how
you relate to your teachers
um how you um relate to really anyone
how you relate at work
um so this has everything to do with
those formative childhood years but I
kind of see it across the scope with
um you know marriages really marriages
that's a big thing because you're yoked
up with someone
uh all the time yeah and at least when
you're in friendships and in
relationships you get breaks uh but you
don't get that when you're in the
marriage so you see it play out a lot in
romantic relationships but it also plays
out in all of our relationships
friendships uh work relationships is
pretty much any relationship we have and
ultimately also how we see God and then
how we think of ourselves okay that that
um you know I'm sitting there listening
to you and thinking
boy that's that's kind of a bummer like
we're all starting out as a negative
that doesn't seem to be very encouraging
right out of the gate but I think you're
going to talk to us a little bit later
about how we can heal from that right
yeah yeah I will definitely there is
hope you are not
um you are not uh hopeless in this
situation there is a way to heal from
attachment disorder but I'll kind of go
back to
um why why that's the case why did why
do we start off in the negative well we
start off in the negative because in the
beginning In the Garden of Eden uh we
had a complete connection to God
um Jesus connected with Adam and Eve in
the cool of the day so he had a close
attachment to them from the very
beginning now attachment disorder if you
just look up attachment disorder you
typically won't see this I have put like
a spiritual connotation on it because I
believe that it is very spiritual how we
connect and attach to other people and
so Jesus dwelt with them every day in
the cool of the day unfortunately as a
result of Disobedience and as a result
of sin we now have a Detachment from God
we were we were we had to leave the
Garden of Eden and now we kind of have
to make our way back and so God has
created a pathway for us to be able to
make our way back to him but it takes
work before it was just the Easy Flow it
was an easy connection with him and us
but now we have to actually
um do more now you have the whole sin
problem you have
um
the same problem that's it what more can
you say that keeps us that causes a
division between us and him and that's
why it starts out
um off the bat in the negative so I'm
curious
um because we haven't talked about what
I'm about to throw at everybody
have you ever had a relationship
um that affected you in the negative in
kind of a a significant way and what I
mean by that is have you ever had a
relationship that affected you in a way
that
affected how you relate to God
have you yes okay like a family
relationship or was it like a another
friendship
um I would say family I think that's
where it starts okay how about you Brad
I I can't think of one I'm working on
that can't think of one he sounds like
he's pretty good I'm like you secure
yeah okay I I would say that I I have
how about you danitra have you had any
relationship like that I have and I can
give an example because I'm pretty
transparent
um my father I had a
um a lot of Abandonment and rejection
that I experienced from him and the the
thing with my father is I was very
attached to him emotionally so when the
rejection in the abandonment happened at
different stages in my life it it in a
sense um it affected my whole identity
because I had attached to him so much so
that abandonment and that rejection kind
of would kind of was part of my core
belief system and so that was a big that
was a big part of how the Lord led me to
understanding more about attachment
disorder I mean I'm a social worker so I
was taught it but how it applying it to
how it related to my life and actually
going through a healing process with the
Lord was a whole different a whole
different path so there's another area
and one an area that we like to talk
about a little bit
um on our programs if we can get there
that's the media portion
um do you think that media plays a part
in this and I kind of have an idea where
you're going to go because we kind of
talked about this but I want to I want
to throw it out to you guys first can
you think of any examples where you've
seen attachment disorder like she's
described in the media
well social media okay everything in
social media is is attachment okay I
mean this is what I believe personally
because it's not an interaction with a
specific person you're interacting with
people's histories that they've posted
from a long time ago but not only their
histories their best portions of their
life sure and you're not seeing the
whole entire person and so you have a
disconnect there of what of something
that's real from something that's not
yeah what about you I would say the same
exact thing you would have said social
media yeah okay there's another portion
that danitra and I were talking about
just before the show and I was kind of
like
wow that that's really interesting so
she was bringing up uh Disney so talk a
little bit about Disney have you seen
attachment disorder in Disney
look at pretty much and um you know I
grew up with The Little Mermaid
Cinderella Snow White Aladdin and if you
look at each one of their backgrounds
they all had attachment disorders so
Ariel uh where was her mama I don't know
where her mama was you know her mom
looks like you know I remember her daddy
but I don't remember where her mama was
I think her mama died
and that's how she got caught up in that
witchcraft by the way because she didn't
have a mama
I'm just saying you know uh uh Snow
White I don't know what her background
was but I don't remember seeing her mama
or her daddy yeah anywhere
um Cinderella she was with her
stepmother and got abused her Wicked
Woman with the stepsisters uh you have
Aladdin uh Jasmine I don't know where
her where her mom was and now she flying
off on a red carpet trying to get into a
whole new world you know so all of them
had a attachment disorder if you really
look at their background Rapunzel she
was in a dungeon Pocahontas
um what was hers I don't know her
background her parents in the picture I
don't remember seeing her parents wasn't
that part of the tree the the it was
like it was more like ancient um it was
more like uh what's the word like Mother
Earth spiritualism but I don't remember
ever seeing her
I got to think about that when her and I
were talking I was like yeah that's I I
you know I get it's not a real boy but
like Pinocchio you know same kind of
thing gotcha pedo no mama you know so
all these broken parental relationships
and that's what all these kids are
feeding on it's like wow that's really
interesting yeah it I I
um it's just interesting how Satan knows
how to play
play it out in the media so so Seven
Dwarfs weren't her parents no I think
they found those in the woods somewhere
what is that okay all right I know yeah
yeah yeah so it definitely impacts
um the media and I think what you said
was really good about you put a
different spin on it than I was thinking
I was thinking also
um that you develop you use this the
social media as almost a false identity
you know getting the likes getting the
DMS but none of these so-called friends
are really your friends they're here to
see what you're doing they're here to
dare I say voyeur in on your entire life
which doesn't isn't even actually your
your life right they just want to know
something it's like a television channel
that you turn it you tune into you know
right right right
yeah kind of creepy fascinating honestly
yeah
and then also it also plays itself out
in romantic relationships in the movies
when I we were talking earlier
um two movies in particular I was
thinking about now I haven't watched
movies and it's been a while so you know
there you go but the two movies that I I
remember specifically this whole
attachment disorder and romantic
relationships is um the what is it the
breakup and the breakup Jennifer Aniston
and I can't remember the other God the
dude's name but they
um they were breaking up and he had more
of an avoidant attachment and she had
more of an anxious attachment I'll go
into the different styles okay
um but she wanted him to help she was
upset that he was not engaging he wasn't
one to be a part of the family he was
just just engulfed in his video game and
um that night or the next day after they
had this whole debacle with her family
and dinner that's when they ended up
breaking up and from there it there was
this ping pong that was happening he
would do things in the OR she and she
would react and she would do something
and then he would react and she would do
something and he would react until it
boiled down to they were supposed to go
to like some she had invited him to some
some concert and
he stood her up and she came home and
cried and once she was done with the
relationship then he became more anxious
and wanted to be with her so it's
interesting how it it causes this ping
pong in relationships and usually
um there there aren't two I'll break
down the different styles there's four
different styles there's secure
attachment anxious attachment
avoidant and disorganized and so the
securely attached is the securely
attached the securely attached person is
comfortable with people coming and going
okay in the relationship they're
comfortable if you're close they're
comfortable when you leave and if you're
not close and they know who they are
they know
um they know who they are outside of
that person the anxious attached person
is preoccupied with people staying so
they're very fearful if people leave and
they're preoccupied with if the person
person is going to leave so this is a
Jeffrey Dahmer type thing that's where
it heads that's where it heads wow and
um the avoidance is the person who does
not like to be close at all so they
don't like to commit to relationships at
all they don't want to be close
um they fear intimacy so they fear being
too close and then to disorganize
usually is someone who has had a lot of
trauma so that is someone who vacillates
between the two so the avoidant are they
basically kind of pushing people away
they're pushing people we keep them
close enough but keep push them away
they don't keep them they keep them
close no they don't keep them close when
the person gets too close
so they don't have a desire to be close
to other people in a in a in a deep
intimate it's the main they never form
what you would call like a deep
meaningful relationship no it's hard to
get to know them if they are in
marriages they're not there's a barrier
there's a barrier and that anxious
attached in the avoidant usually pair up
okay so the anxious attached is
preoccupied with the avoidant person
because their fear intimacy and
closeness so they are fearful they are
preoccupied with trying to get them to
be attached to them and then the
avoidant is scared of being attached so
they pull away it seems like you see
these kind of relationships play out in
front of you in some people's lives you
know there's and it sounds very
stereotypical but there's the woman that
gets involved in an abusive relationship
you know and she might be able to escape
that but then the next thing you know
she's in the same relationship again and
it just keeps repeating and repeating
and repeating I've seen men that way too
yeah and and I'm thinking of men the
same way you know they're kind of the
abuser type and you know keep I don't
know it's just strange I've known people
and I'm not naming names obviously but
I've known friends of mine that have had
many many divorces and you and and I've
been with them very close to them and
they keep whether it is accepting the
wrong type of woman or they are causing
the problem in their own life in their
in their private time some things
something something different about it
it's very interesting yeah and it's
interesting because the further you get
um there's a spectrum sure right so
there's like secure and then there's
like anxious avoidance and you get
further and further and further and as
you become more anxious you can end up
having borderline personality disorder
because it's a neediness it's a or that
histrionic personality disorder
um where you're constantly putting
yourself out there constantly wanting to
be seen constantly feeling like you're
not needed and wanting to be needed by
someone else it's a neediness that
typically a lot of women have but men
have it too it's not just women and we
can give that off to the other person
and then they'll avoid it
you know I think when you said Jeffrey
Dahmer that's how well I don't know if
Jeffrey Dahmer was a narcissist but it
leads to narcissism okay um where you
lack empathy you lack caring for other
people
um and so it's interesting how the
pendulum can swing if these things are
not if they're not healed and work
through it's oh sorry go ahead I was
gonna say I think it's interesting how
culture can play on attachment Styles
because even with he's saying that I can
see how
anxious attachment woman can get with an
avoidant male because the narrative that
is in a lot of romance movies is oh he's
just scared and he's never been in a
relationship before maybe you can be the
one to open him up a mystery exactly and
I think that that sends the message that
you know like you start to lose what
does it look like when a man pursues you
you start to get in your head about like
oh well maybe he's just this maybe he's
just that and you it's like the woman
tries to put all the work to make him
open up when it shouldn't be that way
another thing that I see in our culture
is hookup culture because you have all
these people just sleeping around with
each other and then they're not
acknowledging that you're actually
building an attachment right you know
it's like you're forcing yourself to be
avoidant even though when you separate
there's a lot of anxiety there's a lot
of wondering what the other person is
doing and or there's a lot of regret so
it's just like crazy how Satan plays on
that in our culture well it's
interesting that you brought up both of
those Concepts because the first one I
could see going back to the Disney
movies how even from childhood we are
pre um preconditioned to
think as the woman to want to be chosen
and in the Disney movies you know you
got Cinderella and you got all these
women who are one against the glass
slipper you know I mean in the movies
you are these these Disney movies with
this here a hero or this uh Prince or
whatever you're wanting to be that
special one and so we're preconditioned
to believe that we need to be chosen and
if you don't have a secure relationship
with your father
and you you start to believe this and it
starts to affect how you connect with
men as you get older you know if your
father wasn't there the way he was
supposed to and didn't affirm you or
validate you do you think that leads to
desperation than in relationships right
because if you go so much time and you
don't feel like you've been chosen
then maybe you Market yourself more
aggressively or maybe to the wrong kind
of individual right or you can see
things that aren't there you can think
somebody care likes you and wants to be
with you and they are far from the
mayonnaise thinking nothing about you
you know or he's thinking about you as
somebody else you know so we don't have
it affects our standards it affects our
our boundaries you don't have the
boundaries start to sway and disappear
as you feel more desperate and feel that
you're not going to be to be chosen and
that's why it's so important to develop
a deep relationship with the Lord and
how do you do that you know everybody's
saying you need to have an experience
with Jesus I've heard pastors and
preachers say that but when you have
this deep need to be loved and you were
not loved and um cared for the way you
were supposed to in your formative years
how do you switch that to not rely on
people and on things and rely on God
that's very hard to do you know and so
there's a gap there's a gap and part of
that Gap is what leads to this whole
hookup culture I'm glad you said that I
had a particular client who I was
meeting with and she had told me how she
hooked up with someone and I I
challenged it
um and she just said well it gives me a
surge of intimacy you know and so that's
the same it's it's what we're driven
what we're wanting we're driven to want
closeness and when you're not getting it
in a healthy way you're going to do it
in unhealthy ways because it comes from
our core childhood needs all of us have
childhood needs so if those needs aren't
met those needs are legitimate right and
those one of the core childhood needs
some of them are validation and
affirmation and belonging belonging if
you're not getting those needs met
you're gonna get older and you're going
to try to get those needs met in
illegitimate ways and that's a very good
example is this whole hookup culture you
know it reminds me of the story of Jesus
honestly because when when uh and this
is
there's clues in the Bible that indicate
that
um Joseph his father who was older died
during his upbringing the Bible says
that Jesus was the man of many Sorrows
many things happen in his life that
caused many Sorrows for him and possibly
one of them if you look at some of the
history it's possibly that he he died
where did Jesus get his
masculine uh identity from well every
morning he went and he had worship he
talked with God and he made God the
Father his real father yeah out of that
yeah is that kind of no that's exactly I
mean that is the that's the standard the
highest standard that we need to get to
in order to develop secure attachment
because Jesus was completely secure he
was completely dependent on his father
and I believe because of where we're
going with the end of times we're not
always going to be real able to rely on
people and seek validation from other
people uh what what you gonna do if you
don't have your internet or your social
media and your in your in your DMs and
your likes and you and your all that
stuff what you gonna do if you don't
have that you know if you don't have a
relationship with Jesus at your core we
won't be able to stand you know so it's
so important and I'm I'm so grateful you
brought that up the connection and the
parallel to attachment disorder and
reattachment reattachment is that
complete connection
um to Christ and it's possible because
see in our formative years our parents
are like God to us
the Bible says train up a child in the
way that he should go so that when he
gets older he will not depart and so our
parents are supposed to they're
responsible for keeping us attached to
God and that's why in the Bible there
are certain characters in the Bible that
Jesus spoke the Angels Came specifically
to the mother and told her how to care
for her baby
um Samson's mother in particular the
Lord told her that angel told her how to
care for the baby and so when women have
um are indulged in in tendencies that
are not good for their mind and their
body these things get passed down to the
child and all and and cause more of a
division see we already start off in the
negative but see the mother and where
she is with her relationship with God
and her attachment to God can help to
build the bridge from the very beginning
to the child and God but if that bridge
is not connected if she doesn't have a
secure attachment to the Lord then the
child is going to come out the bridge is
going to be broken and so Jesus has has
to essentially when we get older and we
become adults he has to re-parent us he
has to make up for all those things that
our parents weren't able to do they
didn't blessed bless their heart they
didn't know right anybody or they had
their own attachment issues as well
right I've recognized that um that
because I also I go to a therapist for
something like that and she will connect
the dots of how like she'll help me see
how my family has had those same
attachment cells and it just gets passed
down right
um but to I wanted to ask what is it
that a mother is supposed to provide
emotionally and a father like what are
their roles individually you mean from
the well for I'll start off in at in the
womb because we all have a womb
experience and so it doesn't just start
when you're born it starts when you're
in the womb with your mother at five
months of gestation everything that the
mother feels and thinks gets passed down
to the baby as if they are feeling it
and so if the mother is feeling rejected
if she's feeling hurt if she's feeling
abandoned if she's not connecting with
the father if she is um not wanting to
have the baby she wants to have an
abortion if she doesn't want to be
pregnant pregnant
um so whatever negative feelings she's
having get passed down to the baby and
the baby feels that rejection as if it
is happening directly to them so that's
as early as five months but even before
five months pre-fetus
um as the child is connecting the the
sperm is connecting with the embryo and
making this egg and going up the egg
look don't let me get y'all know what
I'm talking about the pre-fetest part
you know what I'm saying I know I'm no
doctor I'm a clinical social worker and
so the pre-fetest part that holds uh
that whole setup when the when the sperm
is going down there and trying to find
it and all that gets into the embryo and
starts to make the baby
um there's a chemical exchange that
happens between that that pre-fetus and
the mother and at that point the baby is
trying to figure out where they fit with
the mother are they welcome there
and so it happens as soon as conception
takes place that this mother is trying
to connect this baby is trying to
connect with this mother as soon as the
whole process takes place and so it's so
important for one that the mother knows
who she is you know we get into these
relationships and we just want to make
babies and we want to have relationships
and have closeness but we don't work
through our stuff you know and it does a
disservice to the Next Generation
because they don't know who they are and
so it's important that
um the mommy and the daddy before they
start to think about conception that
they emotionally spiritually work
through any attachment decision issues
that they have
um that's one in order to be at a sec at
a as secure as you can possibly be to be
able to validate this child if you're
not secure if you're insecure if you're
anxious if you're avoiding
um you're not going to be able to pull
for those those um childhood need those
Concepts into the baby that validation
that belonging that support so if a
child has is attached to the mother but
the father isn't there or
um it it really disrupts the woman's
identity and her her need for validation
I think that she gets that more from the
father and um order to be able to help
help her to develop like healthy
relationships with males and not look to
them to fill those needs so when a woman
you can almost tell when a woman has not
had that hasn't been validated by her
father because she looks to man to men
to almost replace that what it causes me
to think of is the left and the right
brain so there's the left hemisphere and
there's the right hemisphere so the
right left hemisphere is composed the
more your logic your analytical thinking
and your right hemisphere is pose a more
of your nurturing if a man was not
affirmed by his mother he will have
trouble switching from left to right
brain he'll have trouble going back and
forth because we're supposed to be able
to go back and forth in a healthy way
but if the man was not attached to his
mother the way he was supposed to be he
has a heart he will have a hard time
being nurturing having a loving side and
so the girl if she had too much
lovey-dovey she wasn't validated I think
she has a hard time switching over too
it's almost like you're you're not able
to flow back between both hemispheres
yeah I agree with that because I
actually know someone who didn't I grew
up without their father but grew up with
their mother and I can see now like they
struggle with relationships connecting
with women knowing what women need what
they want how to talk to them how to
approach them and there's just like a
little bit more of a confidence issue
versus if you had the father around to
be able to instill that to be a role
model right I've had a lot of women uh
who were married that I've had to talk
to and help their husbands to help them
to have a nurturing loving side help
them to swing and had have had a lot of
have talked to a lot of women like in
the relationship where I have to help
them to understand what he's thinking
because if he's stuck in a more left
brain thinking he's not trying to hurt
you but it could come across as that way
so I kind of help them to kind of relate
to one another and communicate because
men think completely opposite of what
women think that's a whole different a
whole different segment right but this
can this old attachment issue when we're
stuck in one hemisphere versus the other
when we don't have our own identity when
we don't know who we are when we're not
secure and who we are we can pick up
something that the man is doing the
woman particularly that's where I live
so we can pick up what he's doing and it
could come across as a threat but he in
no way is thinking like that at all and
so it comes from just not being able to
communicate and relate to one another
when you're
in a healed State when you're not healed
your pathways are going and sensing
things that really aren't there that's
really what attachment disorder is is it
affects our amygdala and so the amygdala
of course you probably all know and have
talked about this a lot on the show the
amygdala holds all of our negative
emotions like you said it's the the
alarm system and it's it's a good thing
God put it there to alert us when
there's danger but the problem is if we
have these attachment issues we'll sense
things that are scary that are not scary
and it's constantly firing off and so
someone could say one thing and you take
it in a whole different direction and
that's not even what the person intended
it's almost as if you see and read
things that may not necessarily be there
it goes back to that saying you know
that hurt people hurt people right and
people that are secure they would take
things completely differently because
they don't they don't don't necessarily
assume that somebody's trying to hurt
them or do anything to them but somebody
who has been hurt a lot they're kind of
like on edge you know like oh you're
just trying to hurt me right like for
example one of the things that used to
really give me a lot of anxiety is when
someone says I need to talk to you yeah
when someone says they need to talk to
me but they're not ready to talk to me
right at that particular time like if
you tell me you need to talk to me I
need you to talk to me yeah don't tell
me you need to talk to me and you want
to talk to me next week because I would
that would throw me into a panic and
that's because my father when I was
young he used to say I need to talk to
you and and then he would go do
something and he would really really be
coming back to scold me you know and I
would be so fearful and so panicked and
so those types of sensors would go off
when someone would say I need to talk to
you and and the Lord had to work with me
through that not coming under this fear
and this anxiety just because someone
said because usually it's nothing
you know what I have built up in my had
built up in my mind is nothing yeah you
know I'm glad you brought out earlier
this piece about the job of parents
um knowing that we all started a deficit
in our
sinful nature
we have to point our children to Christ
in order to give them a proper you know
we we might be able to do kind of all
the right things that we know how to to
do but at some point we're probably
going to fail in those formative years
and do something that's not quite right
but if we can attach them to attach to
the one that never fails the one who
sticks closer than a brother it's
certainly going to be better off
otherwise I could see people kind of
walking away and saying well if I did
all the right things and my kid's going
to be fine
but we're still in a sinful world and we
still have problems and and we're still
we still need Jesus right I
oh go ahead are you finished no go ahead
no you can go ahead I can go I was just
gonna bring out a verse um that really
came to my mind based on what she's
talking about and now it's come from
Philippians 4 6 and 7 it says be anxious
for nothing yeah but in everything by
prayer and supplication with
Thanksgiving let your requests be made
known to God and the peace of God which
surpasses all understanding will guard
your hearts and Mind through Christ
Jesus amen so
take it away Britney
I was just gonna say
um along the lines of that and along
lines what Brad said about Jesus
not have like it's alluded that his
father wasn't wrong but he was able to
attach himself to God the Father I think
that
when it comes to Healing
and we know that Jesus had a good level
of self-awareness as well a big part of
healing from attachment disorders is
awareness and because that's one thing
that I've realized is when I'm able to
pinpoint
like where my reaction came from when it
started what happened why I think that
way then I'm able to like I guess
you can
oh what's the word
when you're able to identify those
things it just makes it easier to move
forward yeah because see the thing is
God is our creator and God has to be our
recreator and so if all the all the
times where I started when the Lord
really started to work with me on
attachment disorder every time I felt
triggered I would write the trigger down
and I mean half the time when I felt
triggered I wasn't in a position to pray
but I would write it down and I would go
to God and I would say where is this
coming from tell me where is this coming
from and I would seek God out
um one time I spent four hours in prayer
because I was so determined I was so I
was just I just had I've gotten to the
point where I am tired of sin taking
over my family
um you know I'm tired of reacting to
things that and not being able to be
and do and think the way like Christ the
Bible says let this mind be in you that
is in Christ Jesus
um the Bible says you know be you know
the fruit of the spirit is love joy
peace well I'm up here upset with
somebody because they didn't cut me off
on the road and I want to curse them out
and knock them out you know what I'm
saying that's not the fruit of the
spirit so yeah I get like that you know
I I believe that God wants us to
overcome be perfect because my father is
perfect what does that mean yeah what
does all this really mean well it means
that we need to go back with him and we
need to trace where these things came
from because I don't know you know I
have no idea why I'm acting I can tell
you how I feel yeah I can tell you what
my thoughts are but I can't tell you
where they came from so it's just so
important that we go through with God
and almost like a sifting you know you
put some flour through that sifter and
you see how how it strains it
um that's what we have to go through
with God we have to go through a sifting
process where we narrow down exactly why
I'm doing what I'm doing going in it you
know it's amazing because God will tell
you and I got really caught up in
journaling I was Journal everything that
I was feeling I threw all my journals
out because if somebody broke into my
house I didn't want to think I was crazy
you know because I had so many journals
of all this stuff that was in my brain
that I I was feeling and thinking and
slowly over time as God continued to
reveal what I would do is I would go to
him and I would pray and I would ask him
to remove those negative thoughts I
would ask him to heal my amygdala to
heal my brain I would ask him to rewire
my brain I would ask him to forgive me
for the generational sin because these
things that I wasn't just doing my mama
did my mama's Mama did and so I would go
through a whole prayer every time I
identified the trigger and I would ask
him to download new thought patterns
into my mind and miraculously that would
happen I would think one way one minute
and after I went through that prayer and
the Lord showed me exactly where it was
coming from I would be able to have that
same type the situation play itself out
again and have a different response that
was in line with the fruit of the spirit
and that just helped me to understand
okay this is real this is how you get
real mental healing you know not through
you could talk to somebody tell you blue
in the face but if you can't get on the
phone with your counselor you can't see
them then what you're gonna do yeah you
got to learn how to hear the voice of
God and talk to him directly yeah yeah
and I think it's also about like
identifying the lies because that was
something that I had to do in my own
personal journey through healing and
something that I'm still doing but it's
like there are lies that childhood
um plays a role in reinforcing yes and
then you start to identify God that way
and so I've had to constantly go back
and remember who God is pay attention to
the things that he's doing for me what
does his word say about him and who is
he revealing himself to be in my own
life and that's just it's part of the
renewing of your mind I've realized like
um through my healing process too I
think that's Romans 12 2. the renewing
of your mind
right
you want to read it
Romans 12. yeah you're right yes and do
not be conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that you may prove yes what is good and
acceptable and perfect will of God yes
that verse has been a theme because I
see even when I'm reading to
psychological books like currently I'm
reading the body keeps the score by Dr
Vander vandercole yes bustle Van Der
kolk I believe is his name
um and I don't believe he's a Christian
from how I've read it and he seemed more
like an evolutionist
um but I'm just throughout the entire
book all I see is just the power of the
mind and how there is restoration you
know and just when you renew your mind
or like when the Bible tells to renew
our minds it's because there are things
that have polluted us and there's ways
that trauma wires our brains to think
and to do things yeah oh I want to say
one quick thought yeah
the Lord me that there are three there
are three core there are three beliefs
that we have in order to make up for in
order to make these lies so there's our
core belief system that's how we think
of God
there's our foundational belief system
so that's how we that usually comes from
our mother and our father and then
there's our situational belief system so
these all three things have to be in
line so our core belief system I'll give
you an example when I was struggling and
overcoming some anxious thoughts the
Lord told me I was always very fearful
of my father again I was very attached
to my father but my father was a
military man and so what he said goes I
don't know if y'all got know anything
about military parents but you don't
pull you don't play with them and so um
I thought that God I always thought that
God was not pleased with me because
military men they don't really tell no
news is good news you know they're not
telling you oh you did such a good job
you know they're not saying that but
they're not gonna say anything when you
do something wrong so I I knew that I
was doing some things right but he never
validated validated the things that I
did do right and so my core belief was
that God was not pleased with me I
thought that that's how God felt about
me I'm in the Lord told me that that
foundational belief came from me being
fearful of my father and feeling that he
did he didn't he wasn't pleased with me
and the situational beliefs were that my
father didn't my father didn't validate
me whatever situations that played out
that supported that foundational belief
and that core belief system then my
father was didn't didn't validate me he
didn't tell me he was pleased with me he
didn't tell me I did a good job he
didn't show that he was really
interested in the things that I love to
do though he probably was he just did he
wasn't able to express it because he
didn't know how important that was right
and so under all of those situational
beliefs then there comes the lies I'm
not good enough I'll never be able to do
enough that you know all these different
lies that I was believing that were a
result of the situational belief system
the foundational belief system and the
core belief system so if you want to
break that down and start your
journaling process to get to the lie
because sometimes it's hard to know what
the LIE is right especially when you
believe that your whole life right yeah
and so in order to um you almost have to
have a grid to kind of break it down
with the Holy Spirit and the Lord the
Holy Spirit when I would start writing
it's interesting how he will bring all
your senses together
that's why I made him he made our senses
so that we can hear his voice he didn't
just make us to to have touch I mean
have taste so we could eat good food he
made us have taste and touch and smell
so that we could hear him and connect
with him and so um I just started to
journal and I and I started to hear the
voice of God strongly to make make it
clear that this is coming from your
mother and my mother's not a bad person
bless her she did the best she could do
she did better than her mother but these
are things that he wanted to change and
he wanted to heal and it's time now it's
time you're the one I'm using you if
you're ready to hear me and you're ready
to heal from these things I'm using you
to start this process of working through
with me so if if you want to start that
process to anyone who does you can start
to just start to work through start out
with the lot that some of the negative
thoughts you're having and then try to
talk to God and discover what is that
core belief that foundational belief in
that situation or belief that supports
all of the lies yeah so can you go back
to that that one part you talked about
where the Holy Spirit brings to mind all
senses what do you mean by that can you
give specific examples I I don't think
I've ever experienced that well like
when I would when I would write when I
would use my hands with that can can
aesthetic
in that that means touch when I would
use that when I would use my audio when
I would use my when I when I would kind
of put all those sins in place so touch
then I would read my Bible That's visual
I would be able to touch writing visual
reading the word of God I would be able
to hear the word of God strongly God
desires for us to put all use all of our
senses to be able to hear his voice in a
strong way so thank God he gave us
journals you know he also gave us the
bible to read
um he also gave us audios to be if
someone could be hearing this you know
and listen to this and get more
information research all of these things
he could use so that you can be able to
hear him and connect with him in a
deeper way I love it yeah
I really love when you said that um
that how you commended your mother you
know even though that she did have her
fault in parenting I think that's
something that I've also learned in my
healing journey is to have compassion
for my parents because when you see like
when you start especially because my
family was never really big on sharing
stories about themselves but as I've
gotten older they've opened up and so
you really start to just see more to the
story than how you grew up you know and
I think that's also very important I
think another thing that parents need to
keep in mind is just because you have
children doesn't mean you're going to do
it better like I know a lot of times
like if you're if you didn't have
someone who validated you and you're not
really aware of that you can easily fall
back into the same patterns when you're
parenting if that makes sense you know
and so it just won't you won't
automatically become healthy that work
does need to be done and acknowledged
beforehand that's so true such a good
point that's such a good point I and I'm
so grateful for my mother because I
wouldn't be the person that I am had I
not you know been part of my mother and
I and I used to feel the opposite I used
to hate being I'm like Lord you know
there's billions of people in this world
why did you put me with this family
because you know they crazy you know and
but as I started to work through
um I would not literally I would not be
who I am had I not come from this sperm
and this egg yeah you know so God had to
put these two together because it it
makes up my total blueprint yeah there's
a blueprint plan that God's had
specifically for me and he needed mommy
and daddy in order for me to have that
and so once he got through all the slush
and all the all the slush in my heart
all the pain then I was able to really
see how um my identity shaped from my
mother I would I would be a whole
different person yeah yeah and I and
I've also learned that God can handle
all those negative emotions like I grew
up believing that you know Jesus doesn't
care about anything that I have to say
it's just like you know forget what's
hurting you like you come and read my
word and you listen to what I have to
say and then once I've learned that he's
actually open and he's willing to like
to listen when you have things that are
bothering you and he you know it's just
he cares he cares about every detail of
our lives and you don't have to act
perfect you don't if you're not ready to
forgive someone yet like there's there's
still Parts in my heart I'm just or
parts of my story I'm not ready to
forgive you there are people I'm not
ready to forgive yet but I'm still
working on it right you know and when I
do get to that forgiveness it's just so
I don't it's just relieving you know you
just see how God brought you through all
of that but I just love how God is a
step-by-step person he does care he does
he can handle the entire Journey if
we're just willing to allow him to well
it's so interesting that you bring that
up because the Bible says come in reason
so God wants to come and reason with us
he wants to show us the Deep motives of
the heart the Bible says that um the
heart is wicked and above all things who
can know it so you I don't know my heart
you don't know my heart Only God Can can
knows our heart so he has to be the one
to work with our heart and in addition
to that there are several counts several
counts in the Bible where God tried to
work with um with people to figure out
why are you doing what you're doing when
he talked to Adam and Eve in the garden
he said um who told you you were naked
where are you Adam where are you he knew
where they were you know and he knew
that they were naked
um but he was trying to work it through
with him and part of a relationship
right is communication right he can't be
or everything if you're not willing to
bring everything to him you know and one
specific um
story in the Bible where God was trying
to work with the person in his mess was
Cain
when Cain killed Abel he said where is
your brother yeah and he said um sin
maybe you could bring it up in that that
specific that specific time my brothers
but he says uh he says in my My
Brother's Keeper and then he God told
him you know if you don't work with if
you don't work through your stuff sin
lies at the door and so
um he was trying to work that through
with him he said why are you angry
that's what he said and so he was trying
to work through his anger with him
because when we're not healed we have
roots in our heart and in our mind he
was trying to work through that root of
anger with Cain and he said if you don't
work through this and so so many words
you can read it exactly sin lies at the
door so if we don't work through our Our
Roots that we have with the Lord he's
trying to come and reason with us he's
trying to tell us what's in our heart
sin is the next thing that's going to
happen yeah yeah it's um it's
interesting as I'm reflecting on what
you're saying all the different Bible
stories I can see this playing out and
you know you think of Samuel and Howe in
his formative years you know his mother
did a great job preparing him for his
life and Ministry but then on the other
end
you know he got to a certain point where
his mother wasn't around all the time
and he had Eli and you know the Bible
says about his sons that they didn't
walk in his ways and you kind of it
always puzzled me like what went wrong
there and where is Mrs Samuel and all of
this you know right it's interesting how
um all of this can play
play out in our own stories and I've
really appreciated how you have
shown how this is something that we all
deal with and we've dealt with from the
beginning you know with Adam I've always
looked at that question that you just
brought up not so much as a a geospatial
question but as a emotional relational
question you know where where are we
where are you you know in relation to me
not not like where physically God knew
where he was right but he wanted to know
where he was at emotionally where he was
at spiritually those kind of things so
well it's interesting that you bring up
the Bible characters because one
specific relationship and this goes back
um was uh Jacob Jacob and Rachel and
Leah you know so if you look at if you
look at the dynamic there there was all
kind of attachment disorder uh Leah had
a lot of attachment disorder because he
did not love her he did not choose her
he did not want her and so each child
that she had she was struggling
emotionally
um and then Rachel was fighting with her
sister so she had more of an anxious
attachment she was trying to uh one-up
her sister and so each child she had
um you know in in children were the you
know Reuben anger you got Benjamin anger
um you have Simeon anger yeah Leah had
become more connected to the Lord when
she had Judah and Jesus was through the
line of Judah you know so each child she
had um some sort of attachment issue
with but she had she I think when she
um had Judah she said the Lord has
blessed me each of them had like a
certain type of blessing or some sort of
curse he was upset with him upset with
Jacob because he wasn't connecting with
her and um Jacob I think he had avoided
attachment he was very avoidant with her
I think he was more anxious and wanted
Lee uh wanted Rachel so it's interesting
how this set the pathway for all of us
you know because that's where that's
that's where the generations come from
that's how we how we come we come from
one of the lines and so as a result we
all struggle with this it's not just one
person it's everyone and it's and if you
go back
Jacob if you go back before that Abraham
um look at him and Sarah and Hagar he
lied first of all he lied a couple times
and said she was a sister but in in
addition to that he also had the
relationship with um with Hagar that
that shouldn't happen so that was all
attachment issues and then we have now
this whole other line that ended up
Ishmael the star of the ishmaelites you
know that started this whole pathway of
sin you know and I also think of David
you know David had this issue with uh
intimacy this issue with lust and this
issue with with attaching to women and
as a result it played itself out in his
son's life but if you go back to David
and you go back to before his father
Jesse
um his father was
um had was it was Samuel he was talking
to and when they were trying to figure
out who was going to be the next king
Jesse brought all his other Sons before
Samuel and he did not pick David David
was out in the field and Samuel went and
said it's none of these ones who else is
it it must be someone else so you can
tell there was some rejection there he
didn't even consider David you know so
if you just kind of go back through the
lines you can kind of Trace what was
happening in the family and see how
attachment disorder has played itself
out since the Garden of Eden yeah and
all the relationships so in kind of
bringing this to a close I want to offer
the audience an opportunity to find out
because we've kind of just only started
the conversation how can they reach out
to you in any way and talk about these
issues and if so how would they do that
um so I have a Ministry called
compliment and complete so the whole
reason why I'll give you a little gist
of the ministry but the whole reason why
I created this ministry slash Private
Practice was because I started to
realize man we are looking to people and
things to complete us and not to God you
know people always want to get married
you complete me yeah you know they say
things like that and I'm like that's not
right you're not supposed to do that you
make me whole right and so um I said
Lord uh he gave me the idea of
compliment and complete that we allow
Christ to complete Us in people and
things to complement us and so within
complementing complete it's really a
Ministry that's geared towards women
because I believe that women are the
foundation when when when a woman is
healed and she knows who she is then she
can really impact the whole rest of the
family unit through her influence and so
I have three biblical counseling
programs that I provide to help you heal
from attachment disorder to help you
heal from unforgiveness and to also help
you to discover and understand the lies
you believe and why you believe them and
how to heal from a Biblical perspective
how to heal from Christ because we can
get it you can go out there and you can
find a whole lot of theories sure and
somebody telling you what to do and you
know get your gratitude journal and all
these other schools
and or even spiritualism you know those
types of there's a lot of different
things that you can dip and dive into
but helping you to understand where this
came from how it started how to do how
to re renew your mind through Christ and
how to overcome and so it's
complementingcomplete.com there are
three different programs there or if you
just want to reach out with questions I
have a community of women that I support
and we encourage one another I do
monthly therapy sessions with my group
sessions with the women all of this is
free I have all types of resources that
I've created to help you write out your
lives Journal your lives to help you to
um study the Bible more so it's all
types of free resources in addition if
you want to talk directly that's an
option too okay that's awesome well
thank you for sharing those thank you
for sharing the hope that we can all
have you know that our minds can be
renewed by Christ that's an awesome
promise yes because you know nobody is
going to function very well in this
world without hope so thank you for
sharing that and thank you all for
watching I hope that you have found this
relevant I hope it is awakened an
awareness in your own life because we
all struggle with this from the very
beginning attachment disorder and so if
you find that you're needing some help
some more professional help please don't
hesitate to reach out to Dan nature at
her website compliment and complete and
thank you for joining us and we'd love
for you to comment on this we want to
hear what you guys are are thinking and
going through uh obviously you probably
don't want to be too personal there if
you need to be more personal reach out
to Demetra or through our website
but we want to hear what you're thinking
how did you like the show make sure that
you subscribe so you can find out when
the next show is going to happen and you
know if you were impressed by this we
hope that you will share it as well
because it sounds like somebody else
needs to hear this besides just you and
besides just us so thank you for joining
us we hope to see you on the next show
and take care until next time
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
need to go out of your way to help them
foreign
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]
foreign